JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: --Google
+ this week.
This week we have a special
guest talking to us about the
AdMob ads SDK.
But, as you can see, something
happened to [? Anchor ?]
last week.
I'm not sure what happened.
So he's not with us today.
But we have Tony with us.
So, Tony?
TONY CHAN: Hey.
I'm Tony.
I'm from Hong Kong.
I'm also a developer
of [? SDK. ?]
How are you guys?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: And we have
Raj, our special guest
joining us today from Mountain
View, I believe?
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: Yes.
Hey, I'm Raj.
I'm from Mountain View.
I work as part of the AdMob
developer relations team.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Cool.
I guess we can get started
straight away.
So the Google AdMob ads SDK,
Raj, take it from here.
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: Sure.
So, like I said, I'm part of the
AdMob developer relations
team and I'm going to be talking
about the AdMob ads
SDK today to you guys.
Next slide.
Oh.
So let's start at the
very beginning.
You've just written your Android
application, now what?
There's lots of apps out there
and sometimes they're really
hard to distinguish.
So how do you pull users
in to your app?
One option is that you can
promote yourself by setting up
an ad campaign through a network
to advertise on tens
of thousands of apps.
These are the kinds of ads that
you typically see that
take users right into an
application's Play store page,
where they can download
the app from there.
Next slide.
So now let's say that you've
already got users and they're
using your application.
Of course, one of the ways to
monetize here is to make your
application a paid app.
But the reality is that people
really love free apps.
Advertising is a great
option here.
It can give you the ongoing
revenue stream that
continuously comes in.
It's also generally easy to
implement, no matter how big
your application is.
Next slide.
And this is what
AdMob comes in.
So let's start with
the basics.
AdMob's a mobile app advertising
network that
allows you to monetize your app
and allows advertisers to
promote their content.
How does this work?
Advertisers provide AdMob ads to
run on its mobile network.
AdMob relies on you, the mobile
app developer, to serve
these ads in your apps.
We also recently announced
AdWords advertisers, which are
in the millions, can actually
buy inventory from AdMob.
This means that if you're an
AdMob ad developer, you've
also got access to these
millions of advertisers.
So on the left side of this
picture, you can also see that
you as app developers can
actually become advertisers
and promote your app with
mobile advertising.
Next slide.
So let's touch on the
promotion aspect
of this for a bit.
So promoting with AdMob lets you
set up an ad campaign and
advertise on a plethora
of apps.
You can target based on
different factors such as
device, country, platform, or
even demographic such as
gender, age, and other things.
There's a number of benefits
for doing this.
If your advertising gets you
in to the top 50 in the app
store, for example, you're
likely to enjoy even more
organic downloads from people
browsing the store.
Cross-promotion is another way
to get users into your apps.
Once you build a loyal user base
for one of your apps that
you've built, you can actually
leverage this to promote
another app.
Your loyal users will probably
be more willing to try other
apps as well.
House ads specifically allow you
to promote any other app
in your portfolio.
So this can even be
used to actually
promote apps beyond mobile.
So that's definitely a thing
to think about as well.
Next slide.
So now back to the
monetizing side.
Monetizing with AdMob
is super easy.
All you need to do is include
the Google AdMob ads SDK in
your app, create a banner view
within your application, and
load ads into it.
Ads from Google advertisers are
then displayed in your app
and users click on the
ads that they deal.
You get paid every time a user
clicks on ads in your
application.
An ad-based business model is a
continuing stream of revenue
coming in to your app.
It scales as you grow.
So as your app gets bigger and
you get more users, you have
much more opportunities
to monetize.
Next slide.
So let's break down how
the numbers work here.
So using the AdMob SDK, you're
actually going to make
requests to AdMob's
server for ads.
In this particular example,
let's say that your
application makes 120,000
requests to AdMob.
AdMob typically can't fill
all of those requests.
A number of factors
play in here,
inventory is one of them.
If we say that 83% of those
requests gets filled, you've
got 100,000 impressions.
An ad impression is actually
reported whenever an
individual ad is displayed
in your app.
CTR, or the Click Through Rate,
is a ratio that shows
how often people who see your
ad end up clicking on it.
Of course, a higher CTR
is a good thing.
It's a good indication of
whether users find your ads
helpful and relevant.
In this example, we've
got a CTR of 1.5%.
When you factor in your
impressions, this turns into
1,500 clicks.
AdMob actually pays out on
a cost per click basis.
So your app earns money based on
the number of actual clicks
that are received.
Exactly how much you make per
click can actually vary
substantially based on
a number of factors.
These include the type of app,
your user base, and general
market conditions.
We actually operate an ad
marketplace, so the price of a
click at any given moment is
determined by the bids that
are being placed by
the advertisers.
If we assume a CPC of $0.10
here, for the sake of
simplicity, it's really easy to
calculate what your revenue
is going to be at the end.
Next slide.
So we tried to make getting
started with the AdMob Android
SDK as easy as possible.
You can check out our
step-by-step tutorials as well
as documentation on
developers.google.com.
If you've got any issues with
it, me and the rest of the
developer relations
team are always
willing to hear you out.
You also need to sign up for a
publisher account on AdMob.com.
AdMob.com is the front end where
you'll be controlling
things related to actually
serving ads within your
application.
To get up and going with the
Android SDK, you've got to at
least compile against Android
3.2, but we've got support all
the way down to 1.5.
Next slide.
So the first step to getting
up and going is setting up
your manifest.
You've got to declare an ad
activity in your manifest.
We've bolded out the
two things that
you've got to do there.
At the bottom you see declaring
the ad activity.
You've also got to make sure
to declare the internet and
access network state permissions
of course, because
ad requests are going
to require these.
We also give you the ability
to handle your own config
changes, so the ad won't be
refreshed when some of the
config changes occur.
Next slide.
So let's look at the code
to create your Adview.
This also is very simple.
You've got to import the
necessary classes from the
[INAUDIBLE]
ads package.
Here we're declaring
an Adview instance.
And you're going to have to
specify an ad unit ID there.
This is the ad unit ID that you
get from AdMob.com when
you sign up for a publisher
account.
You can actually add the view
into the UI and load it with
an ad by giving it an
ad request object.
When you're developing though,
we ask you to make sure that
you're in test mode to avoid
being disabled for clicking on
your own ads.
Next slide.
So one of the things to keep in
mind is that before being
passed to Adview dot load ad,
which we saw in the previous
slide, an ad request can be
customized to allow Google to
actually better target
those ads.
So you can use the ad test
device method during
development to avoid generating
false impressions
by requesting test
ads for specific
devices or your emulator.
You can add any devices
that you've got there.
[INAUDIBLE]
should actually help
you out in this.
It should print the device's
[INAUDIBLE]
five hashed ID for
convenience.
You can also specify location
and demographic targeting
information.
However, out of respect for user
privacy, we do ask that
you only specify the location
and demographic targeting info
if it's already being used
in your application.
Next slide.
You can also track ad life
cycle events like request
failures or click throughs by
implementing ad listener in an
object you passed
through to the
Adview dot set ad listener.
This interface can be
implemented by either your
activity or any other object.
These allow you to do certain
things in your application if
an ad is received or an
ad request fails.
You can also stop or pause
things in your app if an ad
click is going to take a user
out of an application into the
Play store, for example.
Next slide.
So an important thing we tried
to encourage users to do is
use the right ad format
for the device that
the users are on.
We saw that the Adview
constructor earlier takes a
primer which lets you
specify the type of
format that you want.
In our core examples
case earlier, it
was ad size dot banner.
So notice how on the example on
the left we've requested an
ad that is way too big
for this screen.
This is actually our medium
rectangle format.
We recommend that people show
this only on tablets.
It's not a great user experience
when an ad is
taking up 50% of your
screen real estate.
On the other hand, on the right
side, we've got a custom
format that looks
way too small.
You can't actually even
tell what it is.
So at that point, the user
experience is suffering again.
The format we typically
recommend for phones are 320
by 50 banners, which is
the one we've got
in the middle there.
Next slide.
So the most popular banner size
that we have is the 320
by 50 banner, which
you can use on
both phones and tablets.
It's mainly used on applications
developed for
phones though.
For tablet ops, we do offer some
larger sizes such as the
320 by 50 medium rectangle,
which we saw in the previous
slide, and a 728 by 90
leader board ad.
However, the smart banner format
is a new format we
introduced back in April.
These span the entire width of
the screen and have variable
height depending on
the screen size.
Next slide.
So these smart banner ad units,
which we introduced in
the 6.0 SDK, I believe, actually
render screen-wide
banner ads across any screen
size for different devices in
different orientations.
So what these do is they help
deal with the increasing
screen fragmentation across
different devices by detecting
the width of the phone and it's
current orientation and
making the Adview
that same size.
This also solves another problem
of requesting the
right type of format for the
screen mode, so this is
whether the screen is
in landscape or
whether it's in portrait.
And requesting a smart banner
ad is super easy.
We've got a smart banner ad size
constant that you just
pass through to your
constructor.
Next slide.
So we've also got some
guidelines on where your
applications should be placed
in your actual app.
Where your ads should be
placed in the actual
application.
I've outlined some bad
placements on this slide.
So we can start with the one
on the left actually.
Needless to say, don't make your
ads transparent or cover
touchable areas with your ads.
That's generally a bad thing.
The middle example deals with
something sort of similar.
Ads shouldn't be placed where
users will randomly click or
place their fingers
on the screen.
In this example, if you're
playing this game, you're very
likely to slip up and click
that ad erroneously.
Another example of something
like this could be if you got
a children's app, for example,
where bubbles are randomly
appearing on the screen and
you're popping them.
You probably don't want to ads
on a screen like that.
The example on the right doesn't
necessarily cover a
touchable area, but it is very
close to the buttons.
So don't place the ads close to
or underneath the buttons
or any other object
which users may
accidentally click on.
You don't want users to click
on the adds without knowing.
Essentially, try not to put ads
anywhere where you may get
erroneous clicks.
Ultimately it leads to a bad
user experience and bad
reviews for your
app typically.
Next slide.
So let's talk [INAUDIBLE]
Another important facet of AdMob
ads are the filters that
we've got set up.
So the filters tab provides a
huge amount of control over
the ads that show up
on your inventory.
We've got URL, text, category,
and language filters.
URL filters--
pretty simple, they prevent ads
leaking to a specific URL
or domain from appearing
in your app.
Text filters prevent ads
containing or matching text
phrases from being shown.
Category and site filters
prevent certain categories of
ads from being displayed.
An example of this is you can
prevent image ads from being
displayed, which would prevent
any type of image boundaries
from being displayed
in your app.
You can also enable
age-appropriate ads.
So age-appropriate ads are
actually disabled by default.
What enabling these allows you
to do is display ads that are
rated as age-appropriate, so not
necessarily suitable for
all audiences.
Examples of these are gambling
and personal ads.
AdMob actually doesn't accept
ads that promote any adult
products or services.
For the language filter, you
can prevent ads of certain
languages from being displayed
on your app.
Although we do recommend that
you make sure that none of
these languages are relevant
to your user base.
TONY CHAN: Raj, I just wanted
to interrupt a little bit.
So in general for our policy
regarding ads on Android, I
just wanted to add on top of--
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: Sure.
TONY CHAN: So one thing a
developer needs to remember
now is that ads are really part
of the entire application
experience.
So as a policy, the content of
the ads is really part of the
application itself.
So if you use other advertising
networks, make
sure you pay attention to that
because you may actually
violate some content policy on
the Android phone if you're
using ads that do not
comply with our
general content policy.
RAJ PARAMESWARAN:
No, definitely.
No matter what ad network
you're looking at, it's
something that you should make
sure that you're reading very
explicitly.
TONY CHAN: Cool.
Thank you.
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: Yeah.
So going on, we actually usually
tell advertisers to be
as permissive as possible using
all these filters, just
because this does maximize the
amount of ads that are
available to run on your
inventory and ensures that
you're generating the highest
revenue potential that we can
offer as an ad network.
Next slide.
So similarly, there's some
other things that you can
actually do to optimize
your ad settings.
You can also increase your fill
rate by taking advantage
of Google certified ad
networks inventory.
So with this option set, we will
actually attempt to fill
your ad request with not only
ads from AdMob, which
explicitly target mobile apps,
but also ads from Google
certified ad networks and
general keyword targeted ads.
So enabling these provides a
great opportunity to increase
your fill rate and
your revenue.
No code changes are actually
needed here.
We conduct a pretty thorough
certification process before
we let any network in for
third party ad survey.
But you have to remember that
at this time you can't
actually apply any of your ad
filters to these Google
certified ad network ads.
Just something to
keep in mind.
It's also important to know
that you need to set your
refresh rate at the
right amount.
An ad that refreshes way too
often can definitely adversely
affect your CTR.
It doesn't give users a chance
to view the ad and decide if
they are interested
in clicking it.
We usually recommend that users
set their refresh rate
between 45 and 60 seconds.
This can all be managed within
the AdMob's front end
interface actually.
Next slide.
So AdMob's great, but what if
you want to use a different ad
network to actually
maximize your fill
rate and your revenue.
We actually offer a free
mediation service which
developers can use to integrate
multiple ad networks
into their application and make
service site decisions on
how to distribute
their requests
among those ad networks.
So ad network ECPMs actually
usually vary over time, that's
why your seeing that
graph right there.
ECPMs are just your effective
cost per 1,000 impressions--
how much money you're making.
When you're using mediation,
you can actually find tune
your mediation configuration
so that the ad network that
performs the best gets
the most requests.
If you keep track of how each
of your networks are
performing and tune your
request distribution
accordingly, you're essentially
optimizing your
ECPM to make the most money.
So keep in mind that some ad
networks do perform better in
certain markets.
AdMob mediation provides the
ability to enter regional and
country level settings that
override the default ad
network distribution centers.
Next slide.
Getting set up with mediation
is super easy.
Just add your mediation ID,
which you can get in AdMob's
front end, and you're all set.
You don't need any additional
coding and you can even send
special targeting parameters to
specific ad network adapters.
Remember though that if you
are adding third party
networks to mediation, you'll
also need to include their
SDKs and adaptors in
your projects.
Next slide.
That's it for me.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, fantastic.
That looks really easy
to get started with.
A lot of opportunities out
there for developers.
Fantastic.
Thank you very much.
RAJ PARAMESWARAN:
You're welcome.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: So, Tony,
do we have anything on the
moderator for this week?
TONY CHAN: Yeah, so let
me take a quick look.
Yes, I think we got two
questions on moderator.
So let me read the
first one out.
The first one is from
[? Eric, ?]
so what are the benefits of
using AdMob over iAds or
Millenial Media.
So I guess, Raj?
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: So iAd and
Millenial Media are competing
ad networks and they differ in
a number of different ways--
fill rate, ECPM, CPC are just
some of these factors.
What I'd actually recommend is
that you can get set up with
all of these networks using
mediation and see what works
best for you on your specific
conditions.
And that way you can best
optimize your own revenue.
TONY CHAN: Cool.
OK, so the next question
is from Simon.
The question was, I want to
use Leap Bolt and AdMob.
How can I do it?
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: So mediation
is I guess
the answer here again.
So with mediation, we actually
do have out of the box support
for a number of ad networks,
which means we've got
adaptors for them.
If there's an ad network that
we don't have some specific
support for, you can actually
write something called a
custom event.
So what custom events allow you
to do is integrate custom
code in to the mediation flow
so that they behave like any
other ad network that
participates in mediation.
We've got docs with this up on
developers.google.com, feel
free to check them out.
TONY CHAN: Thank you, Raj.
I think that's all we have on
the moderator, Jan-Felix.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, fantastic.
Thank you very much.
So I think that's all we
have for this week.
So thank you very much,
our special guest from
Mountain View, Raj.
Thank you, Tony.
And yep, see you next time.
RAJ PARAMESWARAN: Cool,
thanks a lot guys.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Bye.